hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on monster on a roll
again for another solo guide and today
we're gonna be tackling the tempered
Kirin fight at you get it HR 49 so let's
get started so like I said to get the
tempered Kirin quest you have to be HR
49 ones that to achieve you will get a
quest from the commander to slay the
tempered cure in any coral Highlands
just a quick recap for those who don't
remember a tempered monster means they
do more damage but they still have the
same health as before tempered Kirin is
definitely one of the hardest monsters
in Monster owner world so definitely
need to be prepared for this fight like
usual that's moving to the physiology
report and then into the recommended
gear or loadout to have when we're
fighting Kirin so going off the report
Kieran's horn slash head is the only
bleep point with the horn once again
being the only thing breakable for his
weaknesses he is most weak to fire with
water and ice being the second best and
for ailments sleep and blast are the
best for that category
the recommended gear you should have is
the vitality Mentos you can take a few
hits without actually losing health and
also used the Thunder proof mantle as
your backup when the vitality is on
cooldown thunder proof mental increases
resistance on thunder attacks which is
most if not all of Karin's moveset for
armor I used part of Eragon sets since
it has really good lightning resistance
also recommend mega and max potions of
course to get those quick heals as well
as no bears which we'll get into why in
a bit mega barrel bombs as are also good
but only when he's sleeping
anything else is completely up to you
like powders and rations that is all
stuff that you will have to slide on
your own two really quick tips before we
move into his moveset Kirin technically
has two modes one regular and one
agitated mode one difference is that in
his regular mode his body can be
attacked it just does less damage and
his agitated mode his body is rock-hard
and most of your attacks will bounce off
of him there are other differences but
we will get into those differences in a
second I just wanted to let you guys
know that ahead of time and also when
you're hit by Kieran's moves there is a
chance you're going to contract a
thunder blight this needs to be removed
immediately because this could cause
either paralysis leaving you open to
another attack or causes lots of damage
to you simply eating those low berries
we talked about earlier will get rid of
the effects so make sure to stockpile
some before the fight for his moveset
like I said before it's mostly all going
to be Thunder attacks one move he does
is this a wee thunder move where he
shoots lightning around him they will
land in the same five spots every single
time
for near his top leg and back legs and
one at the top near his horn just like
in the clip shown the agitated version
of this though is that instead of
sending five it's going to be ten
lightning strikes the other five are
going to be Indy five other places that
the original five lightning strikes
weren't the Lightning will basically
surround him leaving you unable to
attack him it's better to wait until all
the lightning is done striking to attack
and then another move is this bigger
lightning strike work here in black
lightning in front of him except it's
bigger and has a bigger area and does
more damage
once again simply running out of the way
of it dodging all that good stuff and
you will completely negate all the
damage for it next move is the lines of
lightning Kieran will summon these few
lines of lightning stay out of the path
there it will basically have a blue line
on the floor if you stand in between
them you'll be perfectly safe you just
have to be in that perfect safe zone if
you want to you can also if you want to
be risky you can use this opportunity to
charge Kieran since it takes a little
bit of time to charge up this move and
you can lend some free hits while he
does this move another move Kieran has
is this prancing attack this actually
does damage not just small damage when a
monster moves and accidentally bumps you
with his knee you can actually be
stunned in days from this move so
definitely watch out for this
he likes the prints and pounce around
the map for some weird-ass reason in his
agitated form though he will leave
trails of lightning where he steps so
definitely be careful if you're chasing
him and he decides to do that these are
the moves that I noticed during my
playthrough so now let's move on to the
areas so the first area has a very big
decline slope which is very useful for
sliding attacks you can also go above on
the ledge and get some mounting attacks
or a breather to heal up if you need to
but just be aware that if you're going
to use the vines don't stay on them too
long because Kieran will zap you and
knock you off to either wait until he's
doing a move and then climb up or be
very quick when you're climbing the
second area is a lot more cluttered than
the first one there's a lot of wedge
Beto's though to get you around that
area of the map a lot quicker you can
use this to escape quickly or to mount
Karin from above there is also one para
toda in a sleep toad
sadly Kiran is resistant to paralysis
meaning he cannot be paralyzed by the
para toad but he isn't resistant to
sleep so use that sleep toad and not the
para toad once he is asleep you could
proceed to load him up with bombs and
blow his ass up to get a lot of damage
for the third area that isn't really
much here either some herbs before you
enter and I believe in extra no berry as
well if you need it and then
for the last area there is a few spore
puffs to hide in if you need to get out
of sight of Karin and a few mil berries
one being tier right once you drop down
if you need some extra and that's it
hopefully you guys are prepared now for
the tempered Kirin fly he's definitely
one of the hardest fights and Monster
Hunter will definitely also one of the
hardest monsters of course but also one
of the most rewarding once you beat it
because it is so relieving once you
finally slave this monster hopefully you
guys are a lot more equipped a lot more
knowledgeable about the play but the
fight before you go into it or if you're
in the middle of this fight and can't
really seem to get the move set down
hopefully you know that more either way
guys that's going to be the end of the
video if you guys did enjoy please sure
to give it a like it really does help me
out
subscribe if you're new I cover a lot of
Monster Hunter content stuff just solo
guides for the characters I've done the
previous ones before if you need to farm
those of course I'm gonna be doing
guides on Later monsters that come out
especially when they're released like
deviljho whenever he happens to release
in the near future as well as other
tutorials regarding like decorations and
other things in the game that might need
a little bit of explaining my two most
recent Monster Hunter video is gonna be
on screen if you guys do want to check
those out and with that guys I hope you
have a great rest of your day and peace
out